[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a este especial de
France 24 con motivo del primer año de
la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania Aunque la
llamada operación especial de Vladimir
Putin comenzó el 24 de febrero de 2022
las tensiones entre estos dos países
datan de años atrás pasando Desde las
protestas del euro maidan hasta la
guerra en el don Vasco en el siguiente
capítulo repasaremos los inicios de este
conflicto
31 de diciembre de 2013 mientras el
mundo recibe el año nuevo en Ucrania en
los árboles de navidad se mezclan con
barricadas es el día número 41 de la que
se conoce como revolución del euromaida
kiev Ucrania 21 de noviembre de 2013
hora extensas después de que el gobierno
del presidente ucraniano Pro ruso Víctor
gianni covich anunciara que no firmará
un acuerdo de asociación con la Unión
Europea y que en su lugar planea
incorporarse a la unión aduanera
euroasiática liderada por Moscú
[Música]
la decisión de suspender la preparación
de la firma del acuerdo de asociación y
zona de libre comercio con la Unión
Europea es dura
Pero la única posible en la difícil
situación económica actual que tenemos
[Música]
ucraniano salen a las calles las
protestas en su mayoría pacíficas se
llevan a cabo en la plaza de maidan
[Música]
con el paso de los días las protestas
toman un tono violento y se recrudecen
ante la brutal represión de la berkuth
la policía antidisturbios que deja cerca
de 100 civiles muertos en casi dos meses
del movimiento
occidente se solidariza con las
protestas Rusia denuncia un intento de
golpe de nacionalista ucranianos
financiado por Estados Unidos
finalmente el 22 de febrero de 2014 y
anucovich huye a Rusia
[Música]
mientras la adrenalina baja en el este y
sur de Ucrania crecen los movimientos
prorusos alentados desde Moscú
la primera manzana de la discordia es
crimea la Península del mar Negro que
Nikita Ucrania en los años 50 el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin toma la
Península por la fuerza y organiza un
referendo para su anexión a Rusia el
resultado oficial 97% a favor las
potencias occidentales lo declaran
ilegal el 18 de marzo de 2014 Putin
firma la incorporación de crimea a su
territorio
divierte tiempo no crean a los que
intimían con Rusia y gritan que otras
regiones seguirán después de crimea no
queremos la ruptura de Ucrania no La
necesitamos
occidente impone tibia sanciones a Moscú
y decide sacarlo del grupo del g8 en
adelante el g7
el separatismo Pro ruso armado se
apodera enseguida de parte de las
regiones y el bastión minero e
Industrial del donbas poblado
mayoritariamente por rusos al este de
Ucrania el nuevo gobierno ucraniano
responde con una operación militar y
Moscú apoya a los separatistas que se
declaran el 12 de mayo de 2014
repúblicas independientes
el 25 de mayo el empresario Pro
occidental
metroporocenco sale victorioso de las
elecciones presidenciales
las primeras medidas que implementará mi
equipo al comienzo y mi mandato tendrán
como objetivo terminar con la guerra
terminar con el caos y traer la paz a
Ucrania
el 17 de julio un avión de maleya
Airlines es derribado por un misil sobre
el territorio del este de Ucrania
controlado por fuerzas prorrusas
causando la muerte de la cerca de 300
personas a bordo la investigación de
Países Bajos concluyó que el avión fue
derribado por un misil antiaéreo book
transportado desde Rusia
Moscú siempre ha negado su
responsabilidad
meses de negociaciones llevaron con la
intervención de Francia y Alemania a la
firma del protocolo de Minsk A fines de
2014 y luego en febrero de 2015 a que
Putin y poros suscribieran el llamado
mins 2 ambos incluían un cese al fuego y
otras prohibiciones que nunca fueron
completamente respetadas el conflicto
continuó aunque con menor intensidad
a comienzos de 2019 en las elecciones
presidenciales traen un desenlace de
película
un joven cómico o vlodimir zeleyanski
arruina la reelección de poroshenko y
queda al mando de un país al borde de la
guerra
post a todos los países posoviticos les
digo
míranos todo es posible
tras esta elección la pandemia de Kobe
19 frenó gran parte de los conflictos
del mundo sin embargo una vez superada
la crisis sanitaria de 2020 el conflicto
en Ucrania regresaría con más fuerza
durante el 2020 el mundo Estuvo enfocado
en la pandemia de Kobe 19 en este
periodo el conflicto del este de Ucrania
pasó a un segundo plano sin embargo tras
superar la crisis sanitaria a finales de
2021 la inteligencia de Estados Unidos
advirtió de movimientos de tropas en la
frontera ruso ucraniana un presagio de
guerra que se volvería realidad el 24 de
febrero de 2022
mientras el mundo Mira atónito las
imágenes de la toma del Capitolio a
principios de 2021 la crisis en Estados
Unidos copa las portadas del mundo
pocos meses después Rusia despliega
alrededor de 20.000 soldados a tan solo
100 km de la frontera con Ucrania en la
que es considerada la movilización más
numerosa desde que estalló el conflicto
en 2014 Washington hizo saltar las
alarmas
estamos profundamente preocupados por la
evidencia de que Rusia ha hecho planes
para movimientos agresivos
significativos contra Ucrania en
diciembre de 2021 Rusia pidió una serie
de garantías de seguridad a Estados
Unidos
sin trucos lo decimos muy claramente no
debería haber una expansión de la otan
hacia el este la pelota está en su campo
necesitan darnos alguna respuesta
los servicios de inteligencia
estadounidenses avisan que Rusia planea
Elevar su presencia militar hasta los
175.000 soldados en la frontera con
Ucrania con el potencial objetivo de
invadir el país a principios de 2022 la
mayoría de líder europeos viajan a Moscú
e intentan persuadir a Vladimir Putin
para que detenga sus planes
decía que Estados Unidos advierte cada
vez con más vehemencia que una invasión
rusa es inminente
Moscú niega repetidamente las
afirmaciones de Washington
nuestros militares se desplegaron
tranquilamente en su propio territorio
realizaron ejercicios militares luego
empacaron sus tiendas cargaron el equipo
sobre rieles y comenzaron a irse pero la
histeria continúa
[Música]
el 21 de febrero los líderes de las
autoproclamadas repúblicas y Luján
solicitan al presidente Putin que
reconozca sus independencias
creo que es necesario tomar una decisión
largamente esperada reconocer de
inmediato la independencia y la
soberanía de la República Popular de
dones y la República Popular de lugano
tras el anuncio de Putin la Unión
Europea acuerda por unanimidad paquete
de sanciones a Rusia al día siguiente el
pentágono vuelve a alertar sobre la
posibilidad de un ataque inminente y
advierte que Rusia ya tiene desplegados
en la frontera con Ucrania a más de
200.000 soldados tambores de guerra
suenan nuevamente en Europa
el 24 de febrero de 2022 durante un
discurso televisado el presidente Putin
anunciaba lo que él llamó una operación
militar especial para desnacificar a
Ucrania columnas de tanques llegaron a
kilómetros de kiev occidente reaccionó
rápidamente con sanciones a Moscú y
ayuda militar para el gobierno de
zelensky
[Música]
el 24 de febrero los temores del mundo
se hicieron realidad
[Música]
decidí llevar a cabo una operación
militar especial cuyo objetivo es
proteger a las personas que han sido
intimidadas y sometidas al genocidio por
el régimen de kiev durante ocho años nos
esforzaremos por la desmilitarización y
la desgasificación de Ucrania y
llevaremos ante la justicia a quienes
cometieron múltiples crímenes
sangrientos contra civiles incluidos
ciudadanos rusos
[Música]
tras este anuncio se reportaron ataques
en todo el territorio y los civiles
colapsaron las vías tratando de huir de
la capital
[Música]
ante el temor de un colapso del gobierno
ucraniano el presidente ordena una
movilización militar general Y promete
quedarse para liderar la resistencia
[Música]
ya estamos entregando armas y las
entregaremos para defender nuestro país
a todos los que quieran y tengan la
capacidad de defender nuestra soberanía
el futuro de Ucrania depende de cada uno
de ustedes
tras el avance de las tropas rusas
occidente adopta sanciones sin
precedentes contra Rusia y ofrece a
Ucrania ayuda militar
[Música]
estas imágenes de filas kilométricas de
tanques rusos A las afueras de kiev
hicieron pensar que la capital caería
pronto
[Música]
sin embargo el esfuerzo de Moscú duró
poco
la fuerte resistencia ucraniana en el
norte del país sumada a las
informaciones de inteligencia
estadounidense asestaron un duro golpe a
la primera fase de la operación de Putin
la estrategia en la segunda ciudad más
importante de Ucrania consistió en
oleadas de ataques aéreos y bombardeos
constantes sin embargo la ciudad tampoco
cayó
[Música]
millones de ucranianos huyen de su país
las fronteras de Polonia y Rumanía se
abarrotan se les quita la orden de
evitar la salida a los hombres de entre
18 y 60 años
las tropas rusas atacan la Costa Sur de
Ucrania para intentar unir el territorio
en poder de los Rebeldes prorusos en el
este ucraniano con la Península de
crimea anexionada por Rusia la batalla
se concentra enseguida en la ciudad de
maripol famosa por ser el hogar del
controvertido regimiento asoft de
ideología ultranacionalista que se
atrinchera en la planta metalúrgica de
asofal El bombardeo ruso a un hospital
materno infantil y genera una Nueva Ola
de rechazo internacional
[Música]
el 21 de mayo con la ciudad de reducida
a cenizas los últimos resistentes del
Batallón se rinden
tras no poder tomar kiev y teniendo un
desastre militar Rusia comienza a
desplegar sus tropas hacia el este del
país
los días 2 y 3 de abril los ucranianos
descubren decenas de cadáveres de
civiles esparcidos por la calle o
enterrados en fosas en la localidad de
bucha A las afueras de Kiero Goku
rechaza las acusaciones de crímenes de
guerra y dice que las imágenes de los
cuerpos son falsas
recordarán que me criticaron por llamar
a Putin criminal de guerra Bueno la
verdad es que vieron lo que sucedió en
bucha es un criminal de guerra
el 14 de abril un gran golpe para Rusia
se hunde el buque en el mar Negro
mientras que dice que misiles ucranianos
lo impactaron
Moscú afirma que fue evacuado debido a
un incendio
tras casi dos meses de guerra el ímpetu
ruso empieza a disminuir y después de no
poder tomar ni kiev la capital ni harkid
la segunda ciudad de Ucrania el kremlin
replantea su estrategia y centra sus
operaciones en el donbas y en el sur del
país en el plano internacional Suecia y
Finlandia solicitan formalmente su
adhesión a la otan y la crisis de los
cereales ucranianos empieza a preocupar
al mundo ante una posible crisis
alimentaria en países en vías de
desarrollo
[Música]
hace exactamente 100 días todos
despertamos a una realidad diferente
hace exactamente 100 días el resto de
nosotros despertamos
con la caída del sur de Ucrania la
guerra se recrudece en el don vass en
los primeros días de junio la región de
severodomías que se convierte en el foco
de los enfrentamientos
con el despliegue de las tropas rusas
hacia el don Baz que comienza a vivir
una relativa seguridad y los líderes
mundiales se animan a visitar la capital
ucraniana para mostrar su apoyo
Todos hemos visto estas imágenes de una
ciudad devastada que es al mismo tiempo
una ciudad heroica porque es aquí entre
otras cosas donde los ucranianos
detuvieron el ejército ruso que
descendía sobre kiev la balanza de la
guerra se inclina a favor de Moscú en el
don Baz el 25 de junio la ciudad de
ucraniana de severodonia es cae bajo
ocupación rusa el 3 de Julio
Moscú toma el control de la última
ciudad de la región del lugars que aún
estaba bajo control ucraniano
hubiese sucedido aquello por lo que
todos hemos estado luchando durante ocho
largos años
el nuevo objetivo de Moscú es sloveans y
kramators sin embargo en este punto la
guerra se estanca y los avances de ambos
bandos se vuelven mínimos
tras meses de guerra otro frente de
disputa entre
advierte que millones de personas de
todo el mundo pueden morir de hambre si
Rusia no permite a Ucrania exportar
cereales desde supuestos se estima que
para entonces unas 20 millones de
toneladas de grano estaban bloqueadas en
los hilos ucranianos
No puede haber ninguna discusión sobre
la prolongación de la membresía de Rusia
en la FAO
después de acusaciones mutuas Ucrania y
Rusia con la mediación de Turquía y la
ONU firman separadamente Los acuerdos de
Estambul que estipulan la creación de un
centro de coordinación conjunto para
garantizar la seguridad de las
exportaciones de granos a través del mar
Negro
el primero de agosto el primer buque con
granos cerca del puerto de Odessa y al
día siguiente llega a Turquía
[Música]
el 6 de agosto Rafael grossi secretario
general del organismo internacional de
energía atómica alerta del riesgo de un
desastre nuclear en la central nuclear
de saporilla la más grande de Europa y
pide una inspección de la planta trazar
dos negociaciones Rusia accede a una
visita del organismo
los golpes que ha recibido esta
instalación y que personalmente pude ver
y evaluar junto con mis expertos son
simplemente inaceptables
estamos jugando con fuego y podría
ocurrir algo muy muy catastrófico
con la incertidumbre de un accidente
nuclear y una guerra estancada en el sur
y el este de Ucrania el conflicto está a
punto de dar un giro inesperado
la guerra se estanca y los avances de
los dos bandos son ínfimos sin embargo
en septiembre kiev sorprendería a Moscú
con una explosiva contraofensiva en el
noreste del país y posteriormente en el
sur buscando apoyo internacional
selensky sale en una gira internacional
que incluyó Estados Unidos y las
potencias europeas
el 29 de agosto con un conflicto
estancado Ucrania denuncia una
contraofensiva en la región de gersón en
el sur del país
[Música]
los rusos se movilizan dejando
descubierto el frente Norte y en
septiembre quien sorprende a las
defensas rusas en el noreste del país
lanzando una contraofensiva en la región
de jarquín en cuestión de días recupera
cientos de pueblos y avanza varios
kilómetros en el este
a lo largo de esta semana se han isado
más banderas ucranianas en el don vast
habrá aún más en una semana
en respuesta el 21 de septiembre de
Rusia anuncia una movilización parcial
de sus ciudadanos
[Música]
repito estamos hablando de una
movilización parcial es decir sólo
estarán sujetos al servicio militar los
ciudadanos que estén actualmente en la
reserva y sobre todo aquellos que
sirvieron en las fuerzas armadas y
tengan ciertas especialidades militares
y experiencia relevante
la decisión Del kremlin genera un Éxodo
de ciudadanos en medio de restricciones
consecuencia de las sanciones los
jóvenes intentan huir generando largas
filas en la fronteras con Finlandia o
Georgia
Rusia que ya había ampliado las
ambiciones de su llamada operación
militar especial organiza referendos en
las regiones de doníes lugans gersón y
saporilla los resultados son aplastantes
a favor de la opción de adherirse a la
federación rusa pero poco creíble para
la comunidad internacional que los tilda
de fraude el 24 de septiembre varias
explosiones darían los gasoductos nord
Stream 1 y 2 cerca de la isla danesa de
born Las investigaciones preliminares
apuntan a un Sabotaje deliberado pero
ningún estado Ni organización reivindica
el ataque
el siguiente objetivo de los ucranianos
es el puente de kers
[Música]
que el 8 de octubre quedó parcialmente
destruido por un coche bomba
en represalia el kremlin inicia una
campaña de bombardeo contra
infraestructura energética y civil en
Ucrania
los daños en la logística debilitan a
las tropas rusas en el sur y A mediados
de octubre las autoridades rusas ordenan
abandonar gerson
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el 9 de noviembre las fuerzas de Ucrania
entran victoriosas en la única gran
ciudad que los rusos habían logrado
capturar
hoy todos sentimos la Euforia juntos no
sé si tenemos siquiera una persona que
no haya visto el vídeo de nuestra gente
en gersón reuniéndose con Los Defensores
ucranianos
el 15 de noviembre el mundo contiene la
respiración
[Música]
un misil cae en territorio de Polonia
país miembro de la otan sin embargo tras
una serie de investigaciones Estados
Unidos señala que se trata de un misil
antiaéreo s-300 disparado por Ucrania y
que cayó en la frontera por error
[Música]
el 21 de diciembre esqui sale por
primera vez desde Ucrania desde el
inicio de la invasión viaja a Washington
se reúne con el presidente biden y
recibe ovaciones en el congreso
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el frío invierno ucraniano congela por
un momento del conflicto pero el primero
de enero un bombardeo ucraniano con los
gimar sobre la ciudad de makivka en
indonías que mata a varios centenares de
militares rusos
Moscú reconoce 290 fallecidos
el 5 de enero Rusia declara un alto el
fuego unilateral de 36 horas
coincidiendo con la Pascua ortodoxa un
cese de hostilidades que ambas partes se
acusan de violar
en los últimos días de enero occidente
dobla su Apuesta por Ucrania y decide
enviar tanques Reino Unido anuncia a sus
Challenger 2 tras unas intensas
presiones de sus aliados Alemania cede Y
promete los leopardos Estados Unidos los
M1 abrams
a pocos días del primer aniversario de
la guerra y con La amenaza de una nueva
ofensiva rusa a gran escala quien pide
más apoyo
ahora Busca el envío por parte de Europa
de casas de combate se les pide sin
tapujos ante el parlamento británico
y se va su solicitud a Francia y a
Bruselas
[Aplausos]
Mientras tanto los combates rugen en el
este Rusia reclama tibios avances en el
don vass capturando la localidad de
soledad y rodeando la ciudad de mooc
Recuerden que a lo largo de esta semana
estaremos presentando una programación
especial como motivo del primer año de
la invasión rusa en Ucrania Muchas
gracias por habernos acompañado y
Recuerden que pueden encontrar más
información en France 24.com
[Música]